i want to talk start talking about ethan
hawk that eastern hot guy i mean
pretty friggin good am i right like
when you get a chance to work
like when you get a chance to work
with someone like him do you do like a
little happy dance
on your own like do you run around your
house a little bit excited because this
must have been really cool
well it's not only it's not that i just
got a chance to work with him i went out
and
sought him out for this role and to be
my right-hand man on this thing because
he's an incredible artist you know he's
a
director a writer he's a creature of the
theater like myself and uh he's just
whenever he he takes on something he
commits fully to it so to have him there
in the trenches with me creating this
this wild uh story was invaluable and i
did lots of happy dances
what tequila are you bringing out when
you're trying to you know have a drink
with them and convince them to do this
with you we try all the flavors i mean
classic soul for me i know it's a little
high-end but man it's it's just so
buttery and delicious
i'm you know that night yeah there was
there i think there was lots of
different guys
i love it you've talked about even your
hesitation to jump on board for this
project
and
to me it seemed like the things that
really got you excited were the
challenges of it is that really the
thing that makes you want to do
something when you see challenges ahead
of you like puzzles you can solve
that's exactly right so you know it's
like you work you do something whether
it's i don't know surfing or rock
climbing or basket weaving the the more
skill sets you get the more you want to
challenge yourself so you look for the
greater challenge and um and for me it
was
how do you
how do you take on this
character that is comprised of many
different personalities
that has a very different background
than i do
uh and bridge that gap and find the
truth there uh and and also create
something that is that is a real
character study within this massive
stage that is the marvel universe yeah
you know the moment this was announced
among fans like myself the chatter
immediately turned to like
midnight suns and this that whole group
that could become a part of something do
you see moonite as the beginning of that
phase
for the mcu
uh not necessarily i mean we really
approach this like this is this one
contained story
um but you know obviously i get asked
like
what would i how could i see him you
know in the future and midnight sons is
definitely a place you know marvel
nights is definitely a place uh um
but it would really be about if if if
the story felt um necessary you know
yeah
how would you describe the challenge
that you rose to
um in creating this character that has
multiple characters
uh that he is that he is
um keeping it action-packed and also
being respectful
to what that is the things that real
people go through
well
so there's a few things there but it was
not only being respectful about mental
illness which we definitely wanted to be
but actually orienting the entire show
to make it an expression of that
struggle right so so a lot in using the
language of superheroes and egyptian
gods um to talk about that internal
struggle that is dealing with
abuse and trauma
and
what you do to survive those things and
one of the things that a human can do is
create different altars whole different
identities that can shoulder that trauma
or
or
or live a life free from that trauma so
it's actually an incredible thing that
happened so that was really important to
do the research to um to talk talk to
people that were experts in it but also
to make the story uh not not just be a
part of the plot but actually make the
whole story about that and then as far
as playing the different um altars
uh it was about
what makes them distinct and treating
them as fully formed individuals
and and
really taking
what they believe to be their
circumstances like stephen believes he's
you know this uh man that works in in
this museum in this gift shop and he's
english uh and uh he's from there and uh
he wants to connect with people but he
doesn't know how um and then him finding
out that he shares his body with
an ex-mercenary named mark spector who's
in the service of an egyptian god um
you know just really finding uh how each
one is a counterpoint to the other was
important
awesome also thank you so much for your
time man and thank you for making this
show it's awesome cool thank you
you